[MUSIC]
The main problem that we face is that our
current growth is not at a recovery speed.
So what a recovery means is that you
grow at more than the rate that you
averaged over the past.
In order to recover.
You gotta get back to where you were, and
so
if you had a shock, like a big recession
that we just encountered,
we have to grow at more than the long term
rate.
So the long term rate in the United States
is about 3%,
we usually grow at about 3% per year.
unfortunately, since the recovery, we've
been growing,
not at a rate above three percent, which
is what we need to get back.
But actually, at a rate below three
percent.
So, rather than recovering,
we're actually getting further and further
away from where we need to be.
So we need to get on a better trajectory.
And the best way to do that,
is to increase investment, to increase
productivity.
And I view that as coming primarily from
four policies.
One is a lower and better more efficient
tax code.
Two would be a better regulatory
structure.
So a more cautious eye to regulation and
regulation that enhances economic growth.
The third would be,
getting the budget under control so not
growing the debt at record paces.
And the fourth would be engaging in more
international trade.
If you look at the US population, we're
less than 5% of the world right now.
We're a much bigger part of the world
economy, but
in order to continue that status in the
world in terms of economic structure.
We've gotta be using the rest of the world
as our market, not just the United States.
And that means more trade.
We've been way too reluctant to extend our
trade over the past three to four years,
and we need to do that more, much more
aggressively.
[MUSIC]
Most economists believe that we should
move to something like a consumption tax.
What is consumption tax?
It means that it only taxes consumption,
it does not tax income.
There are variety of technical reasons for
that.
This is pretty much uncontroversial in
the sense that almost all economists think
this is the best way to go.
The problem is making it progressive.
So the easiest way to do that would be
to keep something like a current
progressive tax structure.
But to allow for no taxation of
investment,
if you do that, you're basically saying
we've taxed only consumption.
A variety of ways to that again this is
technical stuff, but
the simplest way to do that is to allow
business to expense,
that means deduct from their taxes all
investments that they make.
That's a pro-growth strategy, and it's one
that most economists tend to like.
Even if you tax the rich as much as you
can possibly tax rich,
again, using the president's numbers.
There's just no way we're going to even
come close to closing the gap
between his projected spending and his
projected tax revenue by taxing the rich.
That's already built into his numbers, and
we can't get there.
So, what that implies is that if we want
to continue on this path of
spending we will have to raise the average
tax for the average American by 50%.
That means everybody would be paying about
50% more in taxes.
The most likely way that that would come
about would be to impose a VAT tax,
which is like a, a Federal retail sales
tax on the economy.
That would have negative impacts on
economic growth, and
so you know, that would basically make us
look a lot more like Europe.
[MUSIC]
We have very large projected increases in
spending.
Most of this comes from Medicare and
Medicaid.
Social security is also a problem but,
social security is a problem that
most people think we can deal with more
readily.
There are some pretty clean solutions to
that problem.
Medicare and Medicaid are much more
problematic as we look down the road.
And what we need to do is, is not cut
Medicare and
Medicaid, but we need to figure out ways
to limit the growth in
those expenditures to move to a more
efficient healthcare system.
That probably means more incentives on the
margin for people to bear their own
costs of their own healthcare, make
decisions in a more rational way.
Some of the Obama Care measures are tries,
are attempts to move in that direction.
We'll see if they work.
Many of the Obama Care measures are
subsidies to the middle class that
actually work in the wrong direction.
So on that you know, we'll have to see if
that's cost saving.
The president claims they are,
I think many are skeptical that they will
be cost saving in the long run.
I think most people who have analyzed that
including the Congressional Budget Office.
Have altered their opinions and
revised upward the cost associated with
President's Health Care Bill.
But we'll see.
[MUSIC]
I think that the Republican view that you
should not raise taxes and
that you have to focus on the spending
side.
Comes from the view that incentives
matter, and
that incentives matter a whole lot.
And if you start taxing people, eventually
the money is going to move abroad.
And by the way, that's not because
Americans are going to invest elsewhere.
The marginal dollar of investment in the
United States is
not coming from an American, it's coming
from a Brit or from a.
A Dutch person or from a German who is
investing in the United States and
they can go anywhere with their money.
So, as we start raising taxes, those
money,
those dollars are going to go elsewhere
and that's the concern.
I think the Democrats have a somewhat
different view.
Their view is that we can do a good bit of
redistribution.
Help the poor to a significant extent
without too much effect on incentives,
without too much effect on growth.
[MUSIC]
During the recession, productivity
actually went up.
And you'd say, how could productivity go
up during a recession?
That's weird.
Well the reason for that is that what
happened was, although output fell,
demand for products, fell employment fell
by even more.
So what that means is that the remaining
workers actually had to work harder.
They had to make up for their colleagues
who were laid off, or
the people who were not rehired during the
recession.
And in fact that happened, and Catherine
Shaw,
one of my colleagues at the business
school.
And one of our former students who is now
at the University of Utah,
Chris Stanton, and I have been doing a
study looking at that specifically in
the context of a firm where we can
actually measure productivity.
And we do see people working harder during
the recession.
Perhaps as a result of their being
somewhat more afraid that
they'll lose their jobs and
they want to protect their jobs and are
willing to work harder to do it.
The question is whether that kind of
efficiency enhancement that occurs in
a short period of time can persist for a
long time,
and whether that can continue to grow and
undoubtful.
So I think these increases in productivity
that we saw for
the short run, are not sustainable over
the long haul.
In order to get productivity to grow over
the long haul,
we got to do a number of things.
Most of it comes from the investment side.
But it means investment in physical
capital, investment in human capital.
That's what Stanford does.
We are producers of human capital and, and
extremely good producers of human capital.
And technology, which is derived from
those two.
So I think that's the, that's the formula
for the long run.
It's not making people work harder.
[MUSIC]